hello everyone thanks for coming I'm
tile I win I'm a staff data scientist
working for a trend oh I'm talking about
attk which is a Python package for not
detection in time serious that we
open-source very recently like well two
months ago so a little bit background
for endo where software company building
industrial IOT platform sense software's
we are startup founded in 2015 about 100
employees currently all over the world
but 3 min of this Palo Alto Houston
which is where I base and Oslo in Norway
and we have a couple of other satellite
offices and one of our key missions is
to prints the sustainability to those
industries that traditionally people
consider is the opposite of being
sustainable like owning gas utility have
its trash heavy transportation and
chemicals all those kind of thing and
we're hiring and so if you're interested
please check us out and so my target is
about this time serious anomaly
detection to peers and so we'll talk
about what is it and why we do it and
then I will go through a live demo and
so what is Namie in time series so
actually it's pretty easy to answer its
anomalous behaviors a long time series
right but it could be many different
kind of thing it's kind of a broad
concept it can be like values just
suddenly hyped and it can be the
volatility suddenly changed it can be
some weird kind of streaming patterns or
if you have more than one time serious
their relationship suddenly changed it
kind of anomalous and it can be also
more sophisticated stuff then there's of
course and so this this problem is
critical for automation in IOT system
especially in in the society system
because we all have a
alarm in this reality system usually it
will cost them at least money sometimes
they cost the lives and sometime
cause the environment which is serious
problem so we want to tackle this
problem and it doesn't sound like very
fancy as for example other topics too
you probably heard today like image
processing motivation natural library
processing many people may think wow
this is something like 20 years out of
30 years old stuff people should already
have a pretty good answer to this but
actually surprisingly not really because
anomaly factors you have already seen
can be very different between each
others so you hardly find a very
universal measure to tackle all the
problems so every time when you have a
new problem you basically need to deal
with it pace by case and another
Challenger that do usually because
anomaly is something that should rarely
happen so you don't really have a lot of
historical event to train a let's say a
supervisor model and so that is one of
the bigger the challenge in this kind of
type of topics and the third thing is
about the accuracy usually need to be
very high as I said because the
consequences can be very serious so we
never want to miss any alarms so
basically we want to all the we want to
hit all the drill alarm but at the same
time then you may have a very high false
alarm rate which will be a problematic
because then you will have a effect of
cry wolf and finally you still miss real
alarm right and so we found that
actually the most pragmatic way to build
a effective model for time certain
architecture is likely
buuuut case-by-case and built from the
very basic instead of threw everything
into a neural network and so usually
this should be zoo based system and the
rules need to be based on knowledge of
the system and we usually prefer an to
provide solutions instead of supervised
solutions which means that we do not
want to use the extremely imbalanced
labels historical labels to train a
supervised model that can be very
unrebutted and here's the example let's
say if I want to detect the
violation office signal pattern from
this time serious I know that I should I
know that I should remove the long-term
trend first and I should remove the
monthly pattern secondly and I should
remove the weekly pattern and then I
should find a way to detect this spike
and so I know what I'm looking for so I
know what the steps should be so attk is
basically a toolkit that provided you
all those building blocks like the
blocks that removes a seasonal pattern
or the block that to detect a spike in
I'm serious all those kind of things and
we found that actually this is the most
common building block for any type of
normally problem and so that's why we
build this you with a unified API so
that people can build their own models
no matter what they want it's just like
Lego right and the reason we think ADT K
will be more helpful for the general
public then those package that you can
find in github which is usually a
information of a very specific algorithm
is because those specific algorithm is
great if your problem happened to be the
problem that that algorithm is designed
for but actually most of time is not
because there's so many different kind
of nominees and so what you want is a
set of Lego instead of something like
this of course if what you really need
is a cyber track of course this is great
for you but probably most of time it's
not the case maybe what you need is
Python right I think everyone in this
room a great Python is more used for the
cyber track and so so that's why we
build a ttk which is basically three
mint major type of building blocks for
those kind of model detector which is
basically you input a time series and it
outputs you what anomalous time point
transformer is you employ time series
and it gives you another time series
which is the feature engineer process to
extract some information from the time
series I will show you in the life
and I will get her that we have multiple
different set of anomalies and you want
to somehow in sümbül them together so
that you have a final decision on
whether or not you should waste a lot
and all this three type of building
block we design and with a unified API
so that you can always combine them in
different ways based on your own case
and the combination class is called type
I will also introduce that in the lab
demo and we also provide some other
modules that can kind of help you to
process the data visualize the data and
they evaluating your models and so now
I'm switching to this true Peter I think
the franchise that's good and so let's
import them basic modules we need this
number I pandas matte palette of course
and that regarding the data structure we
use pandas serious world data frame with
date time index and so now I load a
panel serious but very simple you see we
have this is our late data and we can
start it it looks like this and so let's
start from the most basic thing so what
we call out layer detection which is we
ignore the temporal information between
those data point we just considered them
as data points independently in a space
in the space and then we identify those
one that looks different from others and
of course because we ignore that time
dependency we can just plot a histogram
and you can see that here and here looks
kind of weird with corresponding to here
and here of course and so the most naive
way to highlight those anomalies one of
course its threshold we call it
threshold eighty basically you have two
parameters high and low here I put the
30 and 15 and we follow the API is
similar to secular so you can do fair
you can do detect you can to fit detect
and we do fit attacked here and of
course how that want to hire the 30 or
lower than 15 is highlighted and their
return as the binary serious by default
but you also have the option to say I
want to return a list of event instead
of those kind of point one by one which
can be too big and then you have at
least like this the benefit of general
is that instead of returning you let's
say how many 10 to 20 data points that
are anomalous it will automatically
merge that the data point anomaly data
point that are close to each other so
basically you have 20 data point you
have two time intervals that consider as
anomalous which is more useful in
practice of course and well of course
you may be you already noticed that this
fits thing doesn't really work in this
case because there's nothing to fit
right do you define this Russia though
there's nothing to fit in this model and
so if we want to want to somehow fit
based on some historic historical data
this is probably the simplest model you
can use which we caught the kwang-ho ad
it's basically you look at the
historical data and say ok I consider
from 1% to 99% of the historic data are
normal and if they go be young that it
will be anomalous and so similar API you
will get something like this right and
what this fit now really work and what
is really fitting this absolute high
threshold and absolute low threshold in
this case it is rated at 33 and of
course and but the problem of this is
that you kwang-ho can never go beyond
100 percent or go below 0 percent right
so if your historical data is all normal
then you cannot really use this because
the best thing you can do is set up 100
and 0 and so a very common practice is
to use what we call IQR or inter
quartile
it's basically interquartile range a
difference between 20% and 70% Huang
Chao and you will define a normal range
as 70% 75% wong hau plus c which is a
parameter times IQR or 20 percent 25
percent quantile minus C times IQR and
in this way you can to play with this
number C so that you can go beyond the
maximum number and the minimum number in
your historical data and then define the
normal range whatever in whatever way
you want and in this case we used to 1.5
and so that you get this but if I say I
change it to 3 I don't know what yeah
then everything is normal if I put a to
that there's a smaller set of knowledge
and it's basically it depends on the
user how much tolerance do they want to
put in their model and also based on
their understanding of their historical
data of course and again similar to
quantile a do your training the absolute
high and absolutely so that we this
model object is prior to a new time
series it will directly apply this to
absolute threshold to it so this is
three of the most most basic detectors
we have in this toolkit and we also have
some more advanced stuff like generalize
DSD test which is a hypothesis test the
base the tectors I will not go deeper
into this because of the liminal time
let me check the time by the way okay so
all we saw so far is what we call
outlier detection which which is
basically we ignore that the temporal
relationship between data point but
actually temporal relationship is very
different in terms of anomaly detection
in time series for example if I'm
looking at this stock price I think
everyone will immediately notice oh it
seems something happened here right
because
price jump but actually if you apply a
outlier detection model to this time
series you will not truly find this one
because there's much of value is bigger
than this value and value smaller it
right this value itself doesn't really
stand out what standard is a difference
between this value and its previous
value so what we can now do is the
mostess
is as simple as the time-dependent model
which we caught the persist ad is we
always compare the current time step
with the priest time step and keep
tracking the difference over the entire
time line and then we apply a other
detectors to the difference time series
and then immediately you will see that
most of the time the difference is
pretty small except this single time
step and of course you can whistle arm
here and the problem of this method that
if your time scale changed then it may
give you something that doesn't make
sense anymore for example here we are
looking at that stock price from this is
one week right but what about if we look
at one month
and immediately you will see that it
will recently raise a lot of alarm that
doesn't make sense from this time scale
probably when you zoom is do make sense
but from this time scale it doesn't make
sense because we are looking for
something more like a continuous
dropping or continuous climbing right so
we need to change a little bit and so
what we do it at in this persistent ad
you have a option cut window which is
basically instead of compare your
current time point with the previous
single time point you compare the time
point
current time point with the average of a
previous time window and in this case we
started 24 which means that we compare
every time point with the average of
previous 24 hours and then you
immediately can see something like much
more meaningful like this and this which
is like a continuously chopping of the
stock price and so of course depends on
the use cases maybe in your use case the
this is what you want right and so we
encourage the user to always determine
how those parameters
based on their own use cases of course
and maybe already notice that actually
this kind of strategy can be applied to
many different kind of anomaly types so
we build it as a transformer or a
feature extraction model we call the
double rolling aggregate which is
basically you have is the rolling
averages basically you have a time
window and you keep rolling it over the
timeline and then you keep tracking some
metric over there inside the timeline
and double rolling in that you have two
time window one by one and then you keep
rolling it and at every time point you
calculate something here you calculate
something there and you calculate the
difference between those two metrics and
you keep tracking the difference of this
to say and the folk number in this
persistence ad we're actually rolling to
time windows one is 24 what the length
of the first one is 24 the length of the
second one is one in our case and you
calculate the mean of the value in this
time when they calculate me in this time
when of course the second time we only
have one data point so average is the
value itself and then you calculate the
difference between these two minutes and
then you keep loading it and then you
immediately get something like the
bottom curve so that's why we can
immediately identify here and here at a
time one two when something happened
because you can see this dropping and
this dropping right and if we set the
window back to one to one which is
basically we only wrote two time window
hour of the lens one then you'll get
something like this so that is why we
cannot really detect anything meaningful
in this time scale because everything
looks just a white noise so how can we
use this transformer and apply it to
this persistent ad so if you look at
this persistent 80 object-- and there's
a contribute attribute called pipe and
it is a pep not class object and it has
steps defined how do we built this
hype and it's kind of hard to read but
don't worry about it we have an API
called plot flow chart which basically
visualize this thing into this kind of
visualized a form and you can see that
this permanent has an input and has two
branches the first friend has
transformer and then connected to a
detector the second branch is also
transformer connected detector and then
we have an aggregator to accurate the
result and get a final output and for
each of the node if you want to know
more details you can do that summary and
this is a new feature by the way just
implement like this week it's not in the
in the stable release right now because
somewhere in the audience you need to
prove the PR but you will see that the
information of every node in in this way
and if you want to know more information
even for the more the parameters of
every node you can do get trance and
then you will get it and the phone
number this one is different
ABS which is basically double ruling
aggregates just as what I just
introduced and it's parameter is
calculate the medium of to loading
window the first one is 24 the second
one is one and then keep track it and so
sometimes if you just run this pipeline
it will just you give the input and it
will give you the output but sometimes
you may be interested in the
intermediate results from some node and
we have an API to do that you can turn
this witch into medium to true then
instead of which one without it will
return a dictionary of results so you
need to use those node name to create
the note that you are interested in for
example here I'm interested in this node
and I create from the dictionary and I
got this thing right this is exactly the
same thing as you saw here so you can
see that we can apply this kind of
techniques to many different kind of
nominees for example if what I say is
I'm not interesting in those kind of
spike
I know this is just some random noise I
don't care but I do care when this thing
like kind of permanently or
semi-permanently changed in this case
for example if I'm monitoring the CPU
usage of my cloud server or whatever and
so this is the time point I really I'm
really interested in and then what you
can do at that you still use the same
structure but you change the parameter a
little bit for rolling when you wrote a
double rolling window instead of
calculated to mean you calculate the
medium so that it will automatically all
those kind of out layer numbers and you
also keep this two window the same size
instead of 24 one in this case white we
use five which means that five five and
then we won't get something like this so
all the spikes will be ignored but when
the thing changed here it will be a
spike because your rolling window is
like like this and it's always been like
very similar to each other and you when
you get here the the medium here is
about 20 but medium there is about 80
and then you've got a spike but when you
move to here it will become 80 and 80
and so then so the difference will be
zero again and so in this way we can
detect those kind of level shift what we
call and for those kind of very common
pipeline we just previewed it as a
detector so you don't need to build a
pipeline by yourself and it's cut the
level shift ad in the detector module
and where I am okay actually besides the
main medium those kind of very basic
thing we implement quite a few different
other aggregation operators you can see
all over here and wasn't could be
interesting a that to keep tracking the
standard deviation of the rolling time
window and the comparator compare the
difference because then you can detect
something like the change of volatility
because you you are basically looking to
time when
and you calculate standard deviation
here standard deviation here is always
the same until you get to here it
becomes here and here and here it
becomes different right but when you
roll here
everything becomes same again so that's
why you're rolling difference well looks
like this and you just throw this thing
into a out layer detectors and
immediately our detector well point out
those time point and that is exactly
when the shift of volatility happened
and again this is a very common thing so
we previewed it as a detector called the
volatility shift ad and you can see that
everything looks almost the same as
before except the aggregation a standard
deviation of and besides all those kind
of scalar metrics you can even do
something more crazy for example you can
define a vector match metric in your
time window for example let's say I want
to use the histogram of the time window
and I keep tracking the histogram and
see when the histogram suddenly changed
and I raise alarm or you want to do like
quantiles multiple Kong house and keep
tracking the multiple Kong house and the
rest alarm will change furthermore in
this case in the same example actually I
keep tracking 10% 50% 90% quant house
and I get something like this of course
now the metric is not a scalar but the
three dimensional vectors so the
difference must define as in the vector
space which is a two norm in this case
of course and so that's how it looks
like in this case and another type of
very common problem we see in time
series is seasonality and let me show
you this example first so this is a
traffic some some traffic data from I
think in New York City and
you can see that there's a daily pattern
there is a weekly pattern and close to
the holidays of course you will see some
kind of weird violation of the seasonal
pattern and that is something that is
something people may be interesting
especially for company like uber lyft
and so how can we detect those things
and so we build a pipeline like this the
core partner is basically we have a
transformer cut the D seasonal residual
which is basically we remove the
seasonal patterns and return the
residual time series and then we take
absolute value of those residuals and
put it into a out layer detectors and in
this idea is just a sign check in case
that the user only curious about
negative impacting self positive impact
and so you can see that this this first
decisional note use the model called
classic seasonal decomposition which is
transformer building the transformer
module like this and so it's pretty
naive actually it's just removed the
trend from the by using moving average
and then remove the seasonal pattern by
a defined seasonal period and you get a
residual like this and it's pretty clear
that here here here this time point
corresponding to the time point when the
traffic is much lower than it used to be
and here is when it's higher than it
used to be and of course we always
recommend the user to input their own
period if they really know the period
for example for this kind of case I know
the period is seven day is war one day
and but the model can also detected by
itself in this case it's pretty easy to
detect there so two c333 36 as seven
times 24 times two I guess the data is
is a there's a every half hour and
so after moto is trained you can also
call this attribute called seasonal
which is basically the seasonal pattern
of this 336 time point and by default
actually this this transformer doesn't
really remove the long-term trend but
you can turn it off especially in case
like this when the long term training is
kind of dominant to the values the
absolute values and so if you do not
remove it your residual will looks like
this and it's kind of still
straightforward to be detected but not
so straightforward like something like
like this right because this one used
seriously can just cut it and another
way to handle those kind of problem with
seasonal seasonal patterns or even some
more sophisticated auto regressive
pattern is to use something called Auto
regression ad which is basically we
build a auto regressive model other
words model of course is is is a mapping
between the current time between that
current time want to the previous time
points and so the pipe will looks like
this so we need to curry the previous
time point first using something called
retrospective I will introduce that now
and then you have a multiple time series
which is t minus 1 t minus 2 t minus 3
for example and then you want to view
the regression model from t minus 1 t
minus 2 t monstery to T right and then
you keep tracking the residual and
highlight when the residual looks
different and of course for those kind
of seasonal pattern it's for into a
special case of autoregressive pattern
so it also works here and so this as I
said this retro-reflective transformer
is doing this kind of t minus something
and you can set it up like I want to
look for step
backwards and I want to start from 30
time point a hat and every step should
be 50 steps time point so the output
will be the value t-minus 30 89 80 in my
130 and t minus 180 which looks like
this pretty straightforward but it's
it's handy to have something like your
hand that can do this in just in below
and and the next before I jump into
multi variant models which is about to
request models I want to say that for
other univariate models you can also
applied some multi Byrant series which
means that your input is a data frame
means of the pandal series and so the
model will automatically know this is a
multi color data frame so it will apply
to each of the columns one by one
oops something happen oh I didn't load
the data okay okay so so so here we have
a data frame with five columns and we
use one cup to apply all of them and of
course the output will be a binary data
frame is of binary Series and if you
choose to return list it will be a
dictionary of listing stuff for a single
list and for multivariate models as I
said one of the one of the most common
one is a regression ad which is
basically your regression model between
those time series and try to find the
relationship between them and keep
tracking when the relationship is
violated and this is a very simple
example where we have two time series
the speed of a power generator and the
power get generated and of course this
thing should be very linearly correlated
and so if you want to detect when the
relationship is violated you can use
this request an ad which is basically
keep tracking the regression residual
and then put it into a earlier detection
and so the transformer - detected - to
get the regression procedure is called
requesting residual and it looked like
this so for this very simple lamp oh of
course the residual is always zero until
this period of time when it when the
relationship is violated and so as you
can see we can easily apply all our
detectors to this series and then
highlight this time period and there's a
couple more little more fancier high
dimensional detectors for example
minimum cluster and detector is
basically ignore the temporal
relationship between those high
dimensional time point but I just
project them into a high dimensional
space in this case two dimensional space
speed and power and and do a cutting and
of course you will see oh here's the big
cluster here is a big cluster and here
you have a couple of points and which
looks weird and we identify the minimal
cluster as anomalous if this works for
your use case you can use that but I
would say probably not all the use case
is applicable for this model and the
awesome cycler and the peyote also
provide a lot of high dimensional out
layer detectors which perform time
independent on their detection in high
dimensional space and if you want to use
that you can always use that and we
create a wrapper called out layer
detectors where you just put your other
detector
object in it and the benefit of using
this wrapper is that then you can use
all those attk pipeline and
visualization all those kind of API so
that you can combine it with other
component of attk and in this case we
use a cycler model called local out
layer factors and your PCA is also kind
of pretty common way to deal with high
dimensional data if you believe your
time series is somehow linearly
correlated with each other then they
should be four into
a subspace in the high dimensional space
and then you can built that subspace
using PCA and see when your time point
is four is far away from that space
which may be the problem and of course
this thing is a simple timeline pipeline
and using something called the pc
reconstruction io is a is a construct a
transformer because of time limit I will
not go through this and I probably one
of those you can always use your own
customized function you say for example
in this case I say I know that when
speed times 1.2 is bigger than the power
that is the time when things really
happened then you can just write this
function and then gave it to this
customized detector so that again you
can use that the other API is of the of
the of the package and similarly for
transformer you can also do customized
transformer and for aggregator if your
time seriously is given in this kind of
binary format then this and/or
aggregator is has no difference from a
logic and and and or and but if your
time series is given in this kind of
interval set it will do a union and
intersect instead of an award and of
course and I have talked about the
pipeline actually we have a bunch of
free beauty pathway that we found very
commonly used but if you do want to do
to your own pipeline you can just follow
this like step by step like I have one
node I have another node this node have
an upstream node which is this note
something like that and then you can
always check whether you build a crack
thing using this visualization summary
get to prams I already show all those
kind of thing and if you are pipeline
it's just a linear pipeline sort of
partnered with branches then you can
even use
pipeline which I think this is exactly
the same API as cycle learn pipeline and
yeah and for after you have a mod model
sometimes you want to evaluate the
whether the mother gave you the correct
thing and to compare with the grunt
truth and so again in the case where
everything is giving you as a binary
series you have recall precision and f1
score just like when you do binary
classification but it's a little bit
tricky in time series say if things like
this right if the ground truth is a red
one and the my model return the green
one and this weight overlap it gave you
this weird yellowish number color but
actually you have three known event and
right three no even yet that's right so
you have three knowing event and you
detect the two events and you want to
evaluate how good at this right and if
you do just to a like a point-by-point
binary calculation of the metrics
probably it will not give you something
very reasonable because what you care is
about like whether I capture this entire
event instead of all those kind of small
time steps right and so a dtk if your
input is in this kind of interval format
the recoil function will actually look
at how many event you have and how many
of them is really get detected and by
definitely how do you define whether or
not you detected it is based on this
threshold when I say it's rather than
equal to 0.5 which means that if my
event is covered by more than 50% then I
consider it is detected and in this case
of course all the events are covered by
more than 50% then so
requires 100% but if I reset it to 90% I
really want my event really be very good
detected so that I can cut detect it
then your Rico suddenly dropped to 33%
because you basically missed this one
because this one only cover about like
70% you captured this one and you missed
that one and so that's why this number
is dropped to 1/3 and the same thing for
precision and we found this is actually
very useful much more useful than than
this one actually because in most of the
case we'll deal with time series that
you care this more than this and and of
course you can do things like I owe you
or in the inter sector over Union which
is a more common way to evaluate your
segmentation result for the more image
problems and I think I will skip most of
this thing
I want to highlight this so so sometimes
it's like work once you when you
evaluate those kind of crunches you want
gave them a little bit tolerance for
example let's say if I know
crunches is I have something weird
happen in 6 p.m. and 8 p.m. but my
mother gave me something like 6 p.m.
2 minutes 7 p.m. 57 minutes I still want
to say it's ok they kind of captured
this right based on your use case so
what we want to do - that we gave you a
function called expand expand event
which is basically expand this true
event from one time instance to a time
window depending on how you define how
large tolerance you have for example in
this case I want say on the left hand
side I have feminist tolerance on the
right hand side I also have feminist so
that now when we evaluate the precision
it becomes 1 otherwise it will be 0
because this tune
hit this - exactly but if we have five
minutes tolerance then then both of them
capture it correctly and I think I will
skip all of this except that the last
thing is split training antastic
and actually if you go to psycho learn
it has a function cut the time asturias
split or split time series what they do
a that if you say I want to do a three
fold they will divide your time city
into four sessions and then in the first
fold it use one to Train one to test and
in section one it used to to train and
one to test and the third way is use
three to train the fourth one to test
but we found that actually it's not
always been the optimal choice to do
this kind of split in this way depending
on yours your use case so we implement a
cup of different things for example this
way you can do basically the same same
way to split for the use the first one
to tray and three to test two to 22 2013
one to test or you can even define I
always want to keep a train ratio as 70%
then it were divided into three chunk
and it always split every chunk by seven
to three 73 73 or is cutted into three
chunk but always like incrementally and
77237 to three and seven to three we
found out actually the most of time we
found this could be more useful and also
this one kind of useful yeah that's how
I want to present in this demo thank you
[Applause]
yes this is basically the same as the
documentation in the document our
documentation will have this notebook as
examples and this is basically the same
I'm not online right now but if you go
to in github and there's example which
is almost the same so like we were we
mostly work with industrial companies
like oil company Chemical Company and
they keep for number monitor their
equipment like generators and there
could be like tens to hundreds or even
thousands like different kind of
time-series depend on how many sensors
you'll have on those equipment and right
now it's like they just visualize
everything in this way seriously and
they have someone like standing there
like 24/7 and look at it and when
something happened is likely raise alarm
say oh something happened but it's it's
not very optimal because human will make
make mistake right and so in our case we
build this system so that we connect all
those sensors into a cloud service and
keep streaming the data into the model
and the weather model wrist alarm it
gave a signal back to the system and the
system was rissalah yes that's right
okay thank you thank you
[Applause]